I reimagined Puzzle Box means even more
violence and Mayhem but what exactly is
going on with the all-important lament
configuration in Hulu's Hellraiser the
lament configuration is an essential
component of every Hellraiser movie as
the mysterious puzzle box is responsible
for opening the gateway to Hell and
summoning the cenobites without it the
franchise's terrifying demons wouldn't
be able to show their victims
unspeakable sights and unleash
legendaries suffering basically the
lament configuration is a Hellbound
heart of the entire Saga variations of
the puzzle box have appeared in all
shapes and sizes throughout the
Hellraiser movies the best known
iteration is a simple golden Cube that
shouldn't be tampered with but this has
evolved throughout the franchise for
instance Hellraiser bloodline turns a
whole Space Station into an inverted
lament configuration built to trap the
solo bytes and send them back to Hell
once and for all meanwhile Hulu's
Hellraiser isn't content to repeat the
same old formula either it's a puzzle
the only one of its kind well the puzzle
box featured in Hulu's Hellraiser might
look a little strange at times it's not
the first time the franchise has gotten
creative with the demon summoning Gadget
however David bruckner's unsettling 2022
reboot adds some new elements to the
supernatural artifact which fans might
not have been expecting Hulu's
Hellraiser is a reimagining of sorts but
it can hang out in the same universe as
Clive Barker's original film and some of
its sequels however the shape of 2022's
puzzle box might take some long-term
fans by surprise as there are scenes in
which is reminiscent of a rectangular
antique in other scenes it changes shape
entirely the original immense
configuration did unfurl bends and twist
into different shapes after being
activated so the new puzzle box isn't
completely alien in its presentation
still it's clear that the filmmakers
behind 2022's Hellraiser wanted to apply
some unique touches to the Demonic
object that said fans will be pleased to
know that the puzzle box also adopts a
wholly recognizable form in Hulu's
Hellraiser for instance the very first
shot of the Box the picks a very
familiar image although it isn't long
before that changes nothing good ever
comes from touching the lament's
configuration unless a person is using
it to send the cenobites back to the
shadow realm who lose Hellraiser and
forces this notion as playing with the
Box seemingly comes with more suffering
than ever before by producing a sharp
blade that cuts the user this is rather
fitting as it serves as a precursor to
the center bites arriving on the scene
and carving into flesh playing with the
Box means blood will be spilled whether
it's by the cenobites chains or the
device itself the sharpness of the
puzzle box also means that it can be
used as an effective weapon this is
evident to join the film's Warped
blood-so to climax which sees Riley use
the puzzle box to complete her mission
in the end though she regrets ever
coming into contact with a device in the
first place David bruckner's Hellraiser
has some fun with the visuals of the Box
while also exploring the device's
mysterious capabilities in previous
Hellraiser movies the configuration has
sometimes been seen appearing to
reconfigure itself after sending the
sanobytes back to hell in the 2022
reboot the puzzle cube can seemingly
reassemble itself after being opened by
its user this is noticeable during the
scene in the playground in which Riley
summons the demons before passing out on
the roundabout of course that doesn't
mean that the hell priests can't play
with the lament configuration moments
after Riley wakes up the priest uses the
device to Tormentor and cause her chest
to bleed proving that when the demon
holds the Box bad things happen to human
beings
[Music]
foreign
[Music]